J'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui
d'une toute nouvelle façon de parler d'activités sexuelles,
et d'éducation sexuelle, par comparaison.
Si vous parlez à quelqu'un aujourd'hui en Amérique d'activité sexuelle,
vous vous rendrez vite compte que vous ne parlez pas que d'activité sexuelle,
vous parlez aussi de baseball.
Parce que le baseball est la métaphore culturelle dominante
que les Américains utilisent pour penser à l'activité sexuelle et en parler.
Et nous le savons parce qu'il existe
tout ce langage en Anglais
qui semble parler de baseball
mais qui en fait se réfère à l'activité sexuelle.
Donc, par exemple, vous pouvez être un lanceur ou un attrapeur,
et ça correspond
au fait que vous soyez actif ou passif lors d'un acte sexuel.
Evidemment, il y a les bases
qui réfèrent aux activités sexuelles spécifiques
qui ont lieu dans un ordre très particulier,
desquelles, vous pourrez marquer un home-run
ou frapper un home-run,
ce qui généralement signifie avoir un rapport sexuel
jusqu'à atteindre l'orgasme
du moins, pour le mec. (Rires)
Vous pouvez être éliminé (au bout de trois reprises), ce qui veut dire
que vous n'arrivez à aucun rapport sexuel.
Et si vous êtes un « réchauffeur de banc » (exclu),
vous êtes peut-être vierge ou quelqu'un qui, pour quelque raison que ce soit,
n'est pas « dans la partie »,
peut-être par raison d'âge ou de capacité,
ou pour raison de compétences.
Une batte, c'est un pénis
et un abri de touche c'est une vulve, ou un vagin.
Un gant ou une moufle d'attrapeur, c'est un préservatif.
Un joueur ambidextre est bisexuel
et nos amis les gays et lesbiens jouent pour l'autre équipe. (Rires)
Ensuite, il y a celle-ci :
« S'il y a de l'herbe sur le terrain, joue au baseball. » (Rires)
Et ça veut généralement dire
que si une jeune personne, et plus particulièrement, une jeune femme
est suffisamment âgée pour avoir des poils pubiens,
elle est assez âgée pour qu'on puisse avoir un rapport avec elle.
Ce modèle de communication basé sur le baseball est incroyablement problématique.
C'est sexiste. Et hétérosexiste.
Ça encourage la compétition, l'acharnement pour atteindre des objectifs ;
et ne peut permettre le développement d'une sexualité saine
chez le jeune ou chez l'adulte.
Donc, nous devons trouver un nouveau modèle.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous offrir ce nouveau modèle.
Et c'est basé sur... la pizza. (Rires)
La pizza est reconnue de manière universelle
et que la plupart des personnes associent à une expérience positive.
C'est parti.
Comparons le baseball et la pizza
autour de trois aspects des activités sexuelles :
ce qui déclenche l'activité
ce qui se passe durant l'activité sexuelle
et les résultats attendus de l'activité sexuelle.
Alors, quand est-ce qu'on joue au baseball ?
On joue au baseball pendant la saison du baseball
et qu'il y a un match de programmé.
Ça ne relève pas exactement de votre choix.
Donc si c'est le Bal de Promo ou la nuit de votre mariage,
ou à une fête, ou lorsque vos parents sont absents,
eh bien, vous portez la casquette du lanceur.
Pouvez vous imaginer dire à votre coach,
« Hum, je le sens pas trop aujourd'hui,
je préfère rester sur la touche cette fois. »
Ça n'arrivera juste jamais.
Et lorsqu'on joue au baseball,
de fait, on se retrouve avec deux équipes opposées,
l'une jouant l'attaque, et l'autre la défense,
l'une souhaitant investir le terrain plus profondément.
C'est généralement le rôle du mec.
L'autre tente d'empêcher l'invasion de son territoire.
C'est plutôt attribué à la fille.
C'est compétitif.
On ne joue pas avec l'autre.
On joue contre l'autre.
Et lorsqu'on se présente pour jouer au baseball,
personne n'a besoin de parler de ce qu'on va faire,
ou des bienfaits de cette partie pour nous.
Tout le monde connait les règles.
Il faut prendre position et jouer le jeu.
Mais quand est-ce qu'on prend de la pizza ?
Eh bien, on en mange lorsqu'on a faim pour de la pizza,
ça commence avec une sensation intérieure, un désir intérieur, ou un besoin.
« Hum, je me taperais bien une pizza. »
(Rires)
Puisqu'il s'agit d'un désir intérieur,
on a en réalité un certain contrôle dessus.
Je peux décider que j'ai faim
alors que je sais que ce n'est pas l'heure de manger.
Et lorsqu'on partage une pizza avec quelqu'un
on n'est pas en compétition avec,
on recherche une expérience
que chacun des deux partagera
et qui satisfera les deux,
et lorsqu'on se retrouve pour de la pizza avec quelqu'un,
quelle est la première chose que l'on fait ?
On en parle.
On parle de ce que l'on veut.
On parle de ce que l'on aime.
Peut être même que vous négocierez.
« Qu'est-ce que tu penses du pepperoni ? » (Rires)
« Pas vraiment, je suis plutôt champignon, moi. »
« Peut-être qu'on peut faire moitié moitié. »
Et même si vous avez mangé de la pizza avec quelqu'un
depuis très longtemps
vous continuez tout de même à dire :
« Est-ce qu'on devrait reprendre la même chose que d'habitude ? »
(Rires)
« Ou plutôt quelque chose d'un peu plus aventureux ? »
Bon, donc, lorsqu'on joue au baseball,
et que l'on en parle pendant un rapport sexuel,
quand on est dans le baseball,
on est simplement sensé faire le tour des bases
dans le bon ordre, une par une.
Vous ne pouvez pas à la fois frapper la balle et courir sur le terrain.
Ça ne marche pas.
Et vous ne pouvez pas arriver à la seconde base et dire,
« J'aime bien cet endroit. Je vais rester là. »
Non. (Rires)
Et, bien sûr, avec le baseball,
il y a tout l'attirail spécifique et les talents spécifiques.
Pas tout le monde peut jouer au baseball, c'est plutôt exclusif.
Bon, mais et la pizza ?
Lorsqu'on essaie de comprendre ce qui est bon dans la pizza,
est-ce que tout ne revient pas à comprendre notre plaisir ?
Il y a des millions de pizzas différentes.
De même pour les garnitures.
Il y a même un million de façons de manger une pizza.
Et aucune n'est mauvaise. Elles sont différentes.
Et dans ce sens, la différence est bénéfique,
parce que ça va augmenter les chances
d'avoir une expérience satisfaisante.
Finalement, quel est le résultat attendu du baseball ?
Au baseball, on joue pour gagner.
On obtient autant de points sur les runs que possible.
Il y toujours un gagnant au baseball,
ce qui signifie qu'il y a toujours un perdant au baseball.
Et pour ce qui est de la pizza ?
Et bien, en pizza, on n'a pas vraiment --
on ne gagne pas. Comment gagne-t-on à la pizza ?
Impossible. Mais ce que l'on recherche, c'est :
« Sommes nous satisfaits ? »
Parfois, ce sera des proportions différentes
sur diverses périodes de temps ou avec des personnes différentes
ou sur des journées différentes.
Et on a le droit de décider lorsque l'on est repu.
Si on a toujours faim, on peut en prendre un peu plus.
Si on mange trop, par contre,
on se sent gavé.
(Rires)
Donc si on prenait ce modèle de la pizza
et qu'on s'en servait pour recouvrir le thème de l'éducation sexuelle ?
La plupart de l'éducation sexuelle de nos jours
est tellement influencée par ce modèle de baseball,
et ça crée une éducation qui ne peut s'empêcher
de produire une sexualité malsaine chez les jeunes.
Et ces jeunes grandissent.
Mais si l'on pouvait inventer une éducation sexuelle
qui ressemble plus à un pizza,
on pourrait créer une éducation qui invite
les personnes concernées à penser à leurs propres désirs,
pour qu'elles puissent faire des choix en connaissance de cause,
pour qu'elles puissent parler avec leurs partenaires,
et pour que leur quête absolue
ne soit pas un résultat externe
mais ce qui est ressenti comme satisfaisant;
et nous pouvons le décider.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué
que dans la comparaison baseball-pizza,
dans le système du baseball, il n'y a que des ordres.
Il y a plein de points d'exclamation.
Mais dans le modèle de la pizza, ce sont des questions.
Et qui peut répondre à ces questions?
Vous. Moi.
Donc, rappelez-vous que lorsque l'on pense
à l'éducation sexuelle et à l'activité sexuelle,
en baseball, vous êtes hors jeu.
Pizza est la façon de penser à propos
d'une activité sexuelle saine et satisfaisante,
ainsi qu'à une bonne éducation sexuelle, compréhensive.
Merci à tous pour votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)